antwuan I'm gonna talk by short the talk
by asking about somebody who can't be
here and that's your composer James
Horner who's won two Oscars yeah I want
to recognize him and I want to recognize
what he did for this film can you talk a
little bit about your collaboration the
James Horner it was incredible it was a
lesson in filmmaking all over again it
was the first time I sat with a composer
and went through every part of the movie
every scene and we talked about the
music particularly for every scene and
it wasn't about him ever it was always
about making the picture better and
making the emotions come through and he
became a great friend and we'll miss him
God rest his soul
you know people who saw Mathilde on
Broadway probably saw you playing
Mathilde you want a Tony right yeah I
want to hear about how you met up with
this director and how you met your your
co-star Jay can you tell us the story
yeah okay so I went to the audition and
yeah and I guess they liked me so I then
I went to the I went to the UM I went to
the callback and it was a chemistry lead
with Jake and it was really really cool
we did like a few scenes from the movie
and it was amazing cuz at some point
like I think I don't know who started
crying first but someone started Irish
and then I started crying and it was
like so emotional and it was really
really cool it was amazing and I just
did Antwon start crying cuz that's it
I did start crying it was so good I
started crying yeah because she had
scheduling issues I was like no I can't
happen the Jay said to me I'm not doing
the movie without her Jake we've been up
here together talking about prisoners
we've been up here talking about
Nightcrawler and for every movie you do
yeah a lot of fans of both of you
and we talked before but I think in this
in this case it's really important to
talk about what you discover about a
character through a physical
transformation not about what you do in
your workout but what that work means
what the physical work means to the
development of the soul of the character
you're playing well specifically in the
case of this movie they work hand in
hand you know I didn't know what a box
when I first started you know preparing
for this role and fear was a great
motivator and particularly when Antoine
told me that he was going to shoot the
movie and all the boxing scenes as
realistically as possible and he was
going to have HBO cameraman actually
filming and that he was never going to
go in really very often for a close-up
most was going to be medium shots and
you're gonna have to see our footwork
and he didn't want me to have a stunt
double so I thought wow I think I need
something I need to learn at a box so so
that was that was part of it and and
when you immerse yourself in the world
of boxing and you immerse yourself in
the culture and the history and just the
basic skills I think as I've learned
over time if I give myself a running
start good long running start then if
you run for long enough you get in shape
and you know you start picking up and
stealing from all the people that you
interact with and Antoine put me into
all these situations where I would just
get Clues you know and the physical
transformation for me is not necessarily
important all the time I I believe that
it needs to come from within just
doesn't work and it's no fun otherwise
but in the case of this and something
like Nightcrawler they felt like things
and people or characters that were very
far away and I knew I'd have to shape
myself into them and Antoine I don't
know any directors who have done this
before you actually train with Jake is
that right do you actually get in the
ring with him or what why was that
important that you were kind of training
alongside him I know you've botched for
a while yourself
yeah well it's a trust
we were building trust as a director
it's hard to ask someone to train which
he did seven days a week twice a day
every day in every city we went to so I
knew that if I was in there with him
sweating burning feeling the pain doing
ice baths all the stuff we had to do to
do that we were building trust and he
knew I was a hundred percent in it with
him as opposed to an outsider saying
yeah do do 700 more push-ups 700 more
cities which we would do I knew we were
building trust and also I knew was going
to be days where I would be tired making
this movie and he would be tired and I
can always pull Jake aside which we
didn't I would say you remember the days
when you were being gutted out when you
were vomiting in the bucket and I was
over there and I was vomiting in a
bucket this is a day that it all pays
off and he would get him go let's go go
do it
so that's what we were doing building
trust Rachel I'm going to ask about the
screenplay gives us some clues about
what Maureen and Billy's earlier life
has been like Kurt Sutter obviously has
written a movie that's set there's a
little bit of flashback there's a little
bit of voiceover but in talking to aunt
Alana talking to Jake what kinds of
things were important to you to figure
out how this couple came together and
what kept them together and the life
into which they were thrust that they
seemed somewhat ill-equipped to handle
right well we spent a fair amount of
time talking about that we sort of took
a stroll around New York when we first
started talking about the movie and just
sat in a cafe and kind of mused on their
beginnings and you know talked about our
first interaction ever and that it
probably involved him hitting some kid
in my honor to defend my honor so it was
just kind of building you know that they
have a long history together I think
came out to like 22 years together and
they're really it's them against the
world
so it was important to understand just
how fierce that connection was and keep
building it and and and yeah we were
kind of in our own little bubble really
and and yeah so we yeah just kind of
kept Fermat's with that bubble because
the production design of the film
especially in your home is very specific
and
there's a quick shot of like a row of
belts in the closet and it looks like
this is a couple that has been thrust
into a life that they're ill-equipped to
handle and they haven't designed it for
themselves yeah yeah I mean I definitely
think sometimes they're in over their
head and they're still like two little
kids you know Anton talked about that a
lot that you know they'd probably wake
up every day and they're like how the
hell did this happen how are we getting
away with this and you know trying to
find the joy in it and also not you know
and I think Maureen's trying to not get
in over her head and and try to keep
them grounded and and make sure but you
know they really are fumbling in the
dark half the time you know I mean we
talked about how in his character
smarter than the two of them put
together couldn't she get a call you
Jake yeah yeah I mean I think the I
think the production design is is pretty
brilliant throughout the film in that
you know even when we move into foster
care system you're not you're not you're
not seeing you know this this horrible
space you know that she's put in you're
seeing people who care trying to do
their best the system that Billy and
worrying grew up in that you know I
think was trying to help
probably not succeeding most of the time
is portrayed as sort of some semi
dangerous place that he feels is full of
dangers actually doesn't look as
dangerous and then also their home yeah
is just this a space where they clearly
have someone else designing it someone
else telling them what looks good
summing them someone telling them you
know this is what wealth is you know and
I think I think that's a direct
reflection also on the things they wear
you know and oftentimes Rachael would
come up to me when she was trying on
wardrobe and stuff and she'd always
asked me whether or not I thought
something was sexy do you know she put
it on she like I like everything okay
i'ma ask Jake and the way you know Billy
will really think I'm like oh yeah I
like that dress you know and I mean I
that's we all we lived like that you
know Antoine built a boxing ring in the
production office I trained the
production office every single day if he
needed me he would call me up to his
office you know he would have auditions
there we had readings there we all met
there all the time the wardrobe
department was there
the prop Department was there and so
everybody was sort of immersed in the
training process and Antoine was
desperate to make sure that everybody
knew what we had already done and the
commitment that we have both already
made for every department to have to and
everybody came together there and Rachel
I mean did you get a chance to spend
time in that gym because at one point in
your in the film your character says I
think he's getting hit too many times is
that right that she has been around that
her character knows what it looks like
and knows what's right what's wrong
yeah I figured she would have want to
have a very intimate understanding of
the boxing itself and you know not only
the way he specifically fights so it was
great we would be rehearsing you know
behind a curtain and the other side is
the gym and the guys are going at it and
you just you can hear the punching bags
going in the skipping ropes and you know
right from the beginning boxing we were
completely immersed in boxing all the
time and yeah and I got to get in the
ring and train as well and find out how
hard it is you know I just wanted to
really understand the sacrifice it takes
and and just physically what's required
and yeah I figured she would have have a
good understanding of that you know I'm
gonna ask you about the scene where your
character hits Jake's character it's a
very difficult scene to watch I'm
curious it was a hard scene for you to
do and you talked a little bit about
doing that scene yeah I mean I really
didn't want to hit him I felt no I felt
like really I felt like really really
bad but at the same time I knew my
character had this bubbling anger at him
and also sadness deep in there but I
think yeah I think that like motivation
kind of got me of you like you know what
I just got to do this yeah yeah so